-So, let's just start off, you know, you've often
said that your mission is to eliminate small talk.
So, I'm wondering how that became important to
you and what impact you think it's going to have
to eradicate small talk. -Yeah, before anybody gets
too angry. I'll clarify that for me, small talk has
nothing to do with the content of a conversation.
It has to do with the process. And so, I have had
a conversation about the weather that I would
absolutely put in the category of conversation
that mattered deeply. It happened to be with a man
named Eugene Claudio who is a meteorologist and
we were studying seasonal affective disorder. But
the idea is like, you can talk about the weather
if the process, if you're really curious about
it, if it matters, Etc. And so, I got clear a few
years ago on this kayak camping retreat in the
middle of nowhere Maine and the intention was
to kind of disconnect from the world, reconnect
with yourself and some higher purpose if you
believe there even is one, and very much to my
surprise on that trip. I got really crystal clear
language that was Chad you exist to gently
eradicate small talk and create conversations
that matter. And after that, all these like little
flashes of notable historical figures showed
up for me. And so, can you imagine like Buddha or
Gandhi or Rosa Parks or Jesus or anybody else
who like has made history in some way walking
up to you and saying how was your weekend? I'm
sure they did it, right? I'm totally, I'm sure
that all of them at some point asked a question
like that, but I think the people in my life who
like really change things and shift things have
a way of cutting to the heart of what matters.
And so, you know, a mentor of mine Jeff, 15
minutes before I got married walked straight up
to me no niceties, no hellos, put his hand on my
shoulder and just said, are you present? Because
you really don't want to miss your own wedding.
And 10 years ago, I'm really glad he did that
because I was actually there. And so, I think
a couple to answer your question like
specifically and concretely, I think we could
probably double the amount of good stuff that
happens in the world if we cut out like idle
chit-chat just because. Now, I still think you can
ask, how are you? What do you do? Where are you from?
All these questions and have it matter. But I think
it's also interesting to note like we're we get
in such a routine with the questions we ask that
just by disrupting those questions a little bit, we
tend to ask better questions because they're more
intentional they're more thoughtful, we're not just
like plugging the cassette in and just letting
the tape play and when we move off of autopilot.
That's useful. -I'm really curious about the
role of trust in eradicating small talk, right?
Because if you hadn't met me and I came up to
you 10 minutes before your wedding and said, are
you present? You're like, you're in my way, okay. I'm
on the way, the runway, get out of the way, right? So,
curious your thoughts about that. -So,
let's go back to that scenario. Let's pretend we
hadn't met, which we hadn't 10 years ago. And let's
pretend you crashed my wedding and you walked up
to me. I think it's an interesting hypothetical
experiment to think about. How could you ask that
same question and have it be received well? I guess
it's just an interesting thought experiment. And I
wonder and this is what the first chapter of
ask powerful questions focuses in on is being
clear about your intent and sharing it with
the person that it affects. And so, if you
didn't know me and you crashed my wedding and you
walked up to me, you said, hey, I've got
a question for you and I recognize this a little
bit strange because we haven't met yet. But when
I got married, it was really really useful when
somebody else asked me this question. Can I ask it?
Right? So, I've like shared a really clear intent,
it's framed in the benefit of the other, and I've
also seeked consent, and all before I asked
that like that bigger question. And so, if you
do those things, what might happen is they choose
to not play the game. And they're like, no, please,
don't ask me this question or they choose
to like curl up or back off in some way,
but I think people are more willing to answer
difficult unusual curiosity based questions
if you're clear about your intent and you ask
them for permission first. So, that said yeah,
it's a lot easier to just go for it if you have
a relationship of trust already established with
somebody, but being clear about your intent and
seeking their permission builds trusts as quick as
I know how. Because you're not gonna like walk up
to somebody and read them your bio and be like see,
I'm not a serial killer. -Yeah, text is everything.
Isn't it, right? I mean, you understand important.